if I had only known four or five lawyers
I would most certainly have agreed with
your point but if I've known may be
dealt intimately with about four or five
hundred lawyers I believe that I have a
reasonable basis for that opinion the
last person I remember that ever
conducted themselves in corporate
finance terms in ways that I felt or
even remotely ethical was a fine
gentleman by the name of loeber Landau
who in nineteen it was who was Sullivan
and Cromwell and nineteen eighty-one
stood up to a max and insisted that they
disclose properly in their 10k various
elements of problems with one of their
major molybdenum mines that is the last
time I dealt with hundreds of clients
probably not four or five hundred
lawyers probably thousands of lawyers I
don't overplay who I am i was a bit
player in the big leagues but i was in
the big leagues and i knew what was
going on at the very top the world of
finance and I so I don't believe it's a
matter of prejudice I believe it's a
matter of inference based upon a very
sorry sorry experience i had with people
who didn't begin to measure up to the
other members of my family who are also
lawyers who exemplify the old ways of
doing things of course they ended up
being very poor as opposed to the
lawyers I dealt with who ended up being
very rich now that's not to say every
lawyers like that I we know the people
at the very top levels of the corporate
finance practices of what our esteemed
to be the best firms in the country